hello everybody I'm the Nostalgia Critic
I remember it so you don't have to I
have called this meeting here today to
tell you about this frightful assassin
of ru this assassin poisons the mind
through propaganda and false accusations
about a certain drug that one silent D
chipmunk once put it as marijuana this
parappa ganda is a film that was made in
the thirties and is so fabricated that i
swear even the actors themselves are
puppets
there's a film that can affect your
children or yours or yours or yours do
you start talking while I'm talking
J says the attention span of jelly beans
this propaganda is a film simply known
as reefer madness
yes folks it's time to take a look at a
cult classic reefer Menace an anti-drug
film that's so anti drugs that you'd
swear they were just making this stuff
up which of course they are the film so
misses the mark about the side effects
of marijuana that even after-school
specials are pointing and laughing at
them it's a film everybody loves to mock
and we're gonna look at it today so
let's not miss out on the high life
let's dive right into reefer meds so
after it starts out by saying the story
is fictional yeah because we really
needed that warning the film gives us a
brief forward about the tale we're about
to see no not startled
Wow for a drug so menacing they sure do
give it a nice font ocean area was
reading this when he got to that part
you probably say it all fancy well not
have failed in its purpose because the
dread no wanna maybe reaching forth next
for your son or daughter let's see
laughing this nation got a joint
yes I thought most people just say
Cheetos and watch Spongebob
why don't you just read us the damn
movie hell the full book is sounding
more entertaining than this let's see if
we wipe out this ghastly menace then the
picture will not have failed in his
purpose if its purpose was to bore the
living shit out of us I agree
we then watch a bunch of newspapers as
they display the horrors of the evil
drug police wage war on narcotic dope
peddlers caught in high school
federal echo oh okay the police raid
marijuana flat this leads us to the
widest of gatherings at the school
parents Association dr. alfred was kill
here tells us just how high his high
school is actually die it exists in
almost every city and Hamlet in the
country it might be interesting and
important for you to know some of the
methods used in bringing these drugs
into the country sure go ahead
they are hidden in fake jewelry cases in
the heels of hue women shoes especially
because the drugs can be secreted in
false heal a woman's shoe that's a great
idea
hollow shaving brushes are another
medium folks with first sentence are
often you watch cases this is I do it
recently a huge supply of heroin was
taken it was concealed in an apparently
harmless shipment of 35 barrels of olive
oil now I'm gonna show you how to make a
pipe bomb just so you never figure out
how to do it and more deadly even than
these so destroying druthers is the
Menace of marijuana well that's just
common knowledge no doubt many of you do
not believe that these things do happen
but they cannot happen to you you may
also believe that the facts have been
exaggerated by you yeah let me tell you
of something that happened right here in
our own City so as you imagine he goes
into the backstory of what caused this
thrilling meeting to happen in the first
place apparently there were these
gangstas see who spent most of the time
selling marijuana to teenagers and
providing a place for them to smoke it
the woman who runs the apartment is
named Mei who's going out with one of
the gangsters oh yeah we can get along
with our
young kids up here oh why don't you
button up your lip uh course the good
doctor while telling the story going to
great detail about me putting on her
pantyhose
cuz I've been pretty freaked out if he
was then she slipped on the other
pantyhose slowly and elegantly she
touched her leg reminding herself of the
days when she was a bad bad girl oh yes
she liked those days a lot didn't she
we then get a quick shot of her bra
strap and girlfriend okay okay a couple
of your customers may ya know enough to
know what they're doing
how about those Young's would you bring
up here all right all right listen I'm
gonna blow too easy so he goes to where
all the hip cats are hanging tries to
see if he can sell them the evil weed oh
by the way well I'm sort of getting a
little party Saturday afternoon over at
my grandmother's nothing but party
animals in this town Oh Mary oh you bail
oh yeah well ever around you know I
better give me done with you how are ya
whoa swell imagine somebody swell in the
30s in that everybody seems to be swell
in this movie just take a look well well
well well Wow whoa whoa what the heck
let's just have a swell a meter at the
bottom of the screen to keep track of
how swell things are so the convinced
one of the kids to come with him to a
place called Joe's where they hope to
get them addicted to the stuff
ah you know they really don't use that
many but transitions anymore do it's a
dying good night Mary Jane wherever you
are
hot cha cha cha cha no paper man
I don't know you're never happy he
really freaked out my shine how do they
just say you want to do
this guy
it looks like the missing Dick Tracy
character up on top so after we see him
smoke a joint in the closet not really
sure why we're seeing this we see two
kids named Bill and Mary Lane sit down
at her mother's you know after that
section we had yesterday I went home and
told mother that the trouble with her
pot laws gravy was she hadn't added
three heaping teaspoon fulls of olive
oil boy these two need some pot and fast
it threw me out of the kitchen I don't
one day hello children
hello mrs. like gosh hot chocolate gosh
hot chocolate now then enjoy yourself
he will she will too mrs. Lane Mara
oh thank you kind sir you're so very
very kind
holy smokes the swallow meters just
bursting was wellness anymore this place
is gonna make Pleasantville look like
the fucking ghetto like half dis music
to attending is Romeo
my dear little crock tomorrow shall I
send to thee by the hour of nine I will
not fail
Oh take applause well I'll see you
tonight Mary
what's the grotto so the next day Billy
meets up with Jimmy as they compare
whose day was more swell by chemically I
wasn't doing any place in particular
well then come on IV over to the joke
place with me I'll buy a soda I never
drink tip stuff really so lit us too
strong for you kid
you know how about air can you breathe
air or are you afraid that there's a
chance of water particle might slip in
cuz you know water's pretty heavy too
hello man hello
have you been reloaded just honest no I
mean once all in one room
they're both saunas good God if this is
the sulfur life I hate to see what these
morons are like if they do take
something sure another kids will be
there it gene well I don't know I really
should um well okay I'm out there Jerry
and I'm lovin every minute of it so
Jimmy and Billy get convinced to go back
to the apartment and Puff the Magic
Dragon again wait a minute hold it stop
the marine rau puke something must be
brought to the attention of this
travesty let me guess you have something
to say when do I not have something to
say all right well what do you got to
talk about it may come to an astonishing
revelation to all of you that I in fact
have done drugs in the past No oh if you
may be shocked to find that I was not
always a straight arrow
your arrow says straight as a hedge maze
needless to say I must point out this is
not how high people act you will notice
the constant movement emulating from
their feet notice the incredible amount
of energy that they have in their stuff
this is not a common occurrence the
typical stoner looks more like this
quiet immovable and astonished that he
has two hands you also notice the absurd
amount of smoke that these kids are
taking it yet not once do they ever let
out a smoker's cough even people that
work in a tobacco factory let have a
coffee every once in a while these teens
are smoking kool-aid and why not they
get drunk off of soda apparently well
thank you that was very informative are
you done
oh well never be done but I will stop
for now okay so we have to think Oh God
OJ Simpson off the hook a new cause 911
okay so after the teens get higher than
zoos one of the gangsters looks at this
really crazy laughs now that's a side
effect I believe laughing in a totally
unfunny mode but if that was the case
everybody in this movie would be friggin
high so one of the gangsters approaches
the crime boss and lets it know how
business is going at ten brothers deck
peg boom
Pete Daley all right done damn in P
Diddy a thing move on to the harder
stuff by now
I'm just dope enough to draw the line
selling hot to kids all right Pete you
know what my policy has always been by
the way am I the only one who thinks
their crime lord looks like dr. Cox from
scrubs I only wish you had a couple of
kids the boys are not that admired I'm
always glad to have been read on it I'll
tell you what Barbie if you can get the
kids to just give us their money I won't
have an emotional scene to show I'm not
such a tough guy
Brenda Fraser was dead all along
so Billy or Jimmy or one of the boys and
they would eat he drives the car too
fast of course because of the marijuana
and runs an old man over he didn't touch
him what does he just throw himself in
front of cars just to collect the
insurance
I have no scars no broken bones and not
a scratch on me but I'll sue that
bastard for all he's got there's no
doubt oh wait a minute now the doctors
putting himself in the story come on man
just an ego boner but do you realize
that marijuana is not like other forms
of dope and frankly the only sure cure
is a widespread campaign in education oh
it's all right to talk about education
mr. Wyatt but we educators can't do
anything until the public is
sufficiently aroused now I've got some
Playboy's in the back we can call it pot
porn so they talk about the drugs are
more and of course the terrible
consequences it has on humanity here is
the most tragic case yes I remember just
a young boy under the influence of the
drug he killed his entire family with an
axe Jesus killed his family with an axe
come on marijuana is like the Woody
Allen of drugs pointless ineffectual and
maybe annoying if I were exposed to it
I'd like to take these records if I made
I feel they would be of invaluable
assistance to me in combating the evil
in my school
you're very welcome dr. Gerald thank you
sit down there Oh God are we still with
this guy come on the crowd is talking to
must be bored out of their minds so I
talked to the man and didn't learn very
much then I talked to the boy and didn't
learn very much did I what woman me me
no it was lovely lots of frosting little
touch area moving on Oh candy oh yeah
elegantly he doesn't wish it did have to
bring that every meeting
you were always a fine student you
always had excellent great if you were
being honest with me and honest with
yourself I'm afraid you tell me an
entirely different story
ah I'm worried about something at home
so the doctor tries to see if there's
anything wrong with the kid but doesn't
get anything out of them well that was
boring let's get high again hell is up
with his face ha ha ha ha Mary Lane then
finds the place and tries looking for
Billy the gangster convinces her to take
a few puffs and before you know it she's
seeing colors in the black and white
movie but the gangster tries to take
advantage of Mary Lane as Billy Watson
and misinterprets what he sees tomorrow
shall I send to thee we don't you to
help me feel and how fucking dare anyone
out there make her pretty did not have
sex
Oh Verity no my magic tears as your wife
buzz because they rapin errbody idea
this of course causes him to go to
rampage end hey pretty well for our guys
don't off his ass but then somebody
whips out a gun
oh no the gunshot popped her is it dead
how by shooting the mosquito on her back
so a typical gangsta fashion see they
give the kid the gun and in his stone
state convince him that he shot her what
happened you killed her
that's right you killed Mary Lane while
on the Mary Jane look after I explained
you call the cops and this is your story
oh I can still hear you kid came up here
for a couple of beers what you're up in
kitchen you heard here the shop and you
got in here that's what you're found
just stick to that story why would she
isn't that what happened I go I'm so
high I don't care so they have a trial
four billion oh my god how many times do
you put yourself in your own story
you're the Orson Welles / Kenneth
Branagh of douchey drug films six months
ago what would have been your opinion
regarding the character of my client he
was a fine upstanding American boy a
good scholar a good athlete slug was
chocolates kind of Houston to build an
everlasting pot stop so in the jury room
12 angry idiots sit around and try to
make their vote but he might have been
insane when he did it not only wasn't do
you know what he was doing but supposing
he was insane you will never make me
believe it nor anybody else we take a
first vote hi nice impartial verdict do
you have an opinion without 11 for
conviction one for acquittal I'm looking
at you Baldy but there's a reasonable
doubt about the boys sanity he admitted
it himself I wasn't the first time he
was there yeah I should have smoked all
that pot we got to make an example
before boys like that contaminate all of
our children we can't of every murderer
hiding behind the gadget he's insane
sure they see red before they kill
somebody but who started it crucify him
crucify him crucify him crucify him
so Billy gets the verdict of guilty but
one gangster can't help but feel guilty
himself
hey little puddle solve that problem
laughter
way back
let's travel back in time
Cheka once just then another gangster
comes in to see him in this drug-induced
State I know what you wanted you want to
kill me you're crazy
word of advice you never want to call a
crazy guy crazy you know cuz they're
fuckin crazy
so the gangster goes nuts and attacks
him with a fly swatter while one of the
other people in the building calls the
police by going on yeah yeah apartment
vacant that's in the wait a minute how
could a might get a word in during that
what was she talking to herself by going
on yeah yeah so Eliot Ness and his
Untouchables are sent out to arrest the
people involved and eventually the drug
bust is closed they even get the woman
to confess all the crimes they've
committed including the framing of Billy
for murder bill didn't know I hadn't
killed Mary
it was so doped up they made him dig
ahead well wanted to tell you - oh they
don't live it but this is the truth yes
I'm telling you the truth
a context or the phrases I just left the
way
officer dick chaney believes her story
and sits out to put things right but
after she makes the confession she finds
that life just ain't worth living
anymore and by god it does look like
nice jumpin weather doesn't okay how did
she break that window that hole was huge
it's not like TV guys those things don't
crack that easily ah so Billy's let off
the hook and the gangster set to jail
still still doth his ass apparently I
guess the guard was nice enough to let
him smoke a few before he went into
court
it is recommended your honor that the
defendant be placed at an institution
for the criminally insane for the rest
of his natural life I see no reason why
the request should not be granted this
of course ends our story as our doctor
friend tells us the final message that
we're supposed to take home from all of
us because it is only through knowledge
that we can safely protect them failing
this the next tragedy may be that of
your daughter or your son or your or
yours or yours tell your children the
truth about marijuana is less dangerous
than alcohol but is still some Halloween
it's never harmed a soul in history
except for the people we just made up we
give it to the sick and elderly but
that's only because they're going to die
anyway or yours wait a minute
I got one last thing that I want to say
what is it puke have you are concerned
the possibility of who's actually stoned
in this movie what do you mean well
think about it you have a group of
people who are clearly over paranoid
they do nothing but sit in a room and
stare at one person for hours and they
tell over-exaggerated stories that in
fact never happened oh so what you're
saying
Lisa footprints are stoned off their
asses the only reason they're watching
him is because they believe his head is
a giant bolt in the ball any other
reason he's with them is because he's
paranoia what'll happen if he stops
talking
okay whew you made your put that in your
pipe and smoke it because we already
know it's really in there all right puke
settle down cookies cookies make you say
that I don't know I'm stoned
all right well despite this being
painfully false and of course hokey as
hell this is a fine little bit of
propaganda
there's a reason this became a cult
classic it's so misinformed about what
is trying to inform you about that the
hilarity speaks for itself and while
nobody should think that drugs are one
of the greatest things in the world it's
so fun to see just how extreme some
people will go to convince us that even
the most harmless of drugs are the worst
things in the world it's a lot of fun
and you can see it almost everywhere
even a DVD so if you get a chance check
it out I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember wait I have something important
to say what do you have to say I just
want to say that this film really
affected me and as of today I am going
to quit marijuana cold turkey really yes
I never knew what a horrible effect it
was having on me all these years
Wow okay well I guess some good can come
out of this movie even if it is
incredibly misleading that's right
it's just guru fetch and crack for me
okay I knew there was a catch that's
welcome okay I remember it so you don't
have why is your head a melting new
Photoshop
gosh hot chocolate